families wait to find out what has
happened to their loved ones
salma began sister was working in the
factory the day the fire broke out
she's desperate to find her sister's
body so she can bury her
but hospital authorities told her they
will need a dna test
and that could take weeks as most of the
bodies recovered
are charred beyond recognition
my sister was going to run downstairs
from the fourth floor when the fire
started
but the line supervisor told them to
stay put the fire will be under control
downstairs soon
then they locked the gate by then the
fire spread to the fourth floor
she couldn't escape she has two children
what are they going to do now
many survivors say the front gate of the
factory their only way out
was locked which meant workers were
trapped inside
you can see the devastation all around
me this is the fourth floor of the six
story factory building
this is the floor where most of the
bodies were recovered from
the fire service is still doing salvage
operation
number of people are still missing fire
service officials say
they don't expect to find any more
bodies but will continue their search
till now we have recovered around 49
dead bodies yesterday around four
o'clock we have handed over
the all the dead bodies to the police
authority and then
in turn they have sent all the bodies to
dhaka
medical college and we requested the
families
of the missing persons to contact the
medical
college authorities so that they can
identify their
relatives disasters blamed on poor fire
and building safety standards are common
in bangladesh
one union leader said things may have
improved in the garments and textile
sectors
but other industries are still lagging
far behind
it is complete negligence by the
government
yeah it is true that there is an
improvement in the government sector
and that has happened because there was
enormous pressure
from the social you know sourcing brands
or sourcing countries and international
community was like
watching over but there are so many
manufacturing sectors that exist in the
country
which is absolutely overlooked the
international labor organization
says the rope gun fire highlights the
importance of safety measures
for building construction in bangladesh
and elsewhere
but for many relatives who lost loved
ones it will be a case of too little too
late
and workers feel let down that adequate
safety measures
are not in place tanvi choudhary
al-jazeera
rob ganj bangladesh